bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est en ce qui va démarrer d'ici
quelques minutes pour l'instant la
sonnerie la science n'a pas encore
retenti
on n'a pas non plus vu le président
dudit sert du sénat s'avancer vers
l'hémicycle
je vais vous donner les principaux
thèmes qui vont être abordés par les
sénateurs cet après midi dans
l'hémicycle
tout d'abord et bien la sécurité de la
france
suite aux attentats de vendredi dernier
il y à trois questions qui sont posées
sur ce thème à bernard cazeneuve le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est présent
cet après midi au sénat pour répondre
aux sénateurs ces questions autour de la
sécurité du terrorisme et bien elles
sont posées par les groupes des radicaux
de gauche du parti socialiste et des
républicains manuel valls le premier
ministre est absent du sénat cet après
midi l'autre thème fort de l'après midi
c'est bien entendu la situation en grèce
et là aussi il y aura deux questions sur
ce thème de la situation en grèce une
question du communiste éric bocquet et
puis une question du républicain mathieu
darnaud cette fois c'est michel sapin
pardon le ministre des finances qui est
présent cet après midi au sénat dans
l'hémicycle pour répondre aux sénateurs
donc voilà pour les deux principaux
thèmes abordés
cet après midi lors de ces questions
d'actualité qui vont je vous le rappelle
démarrer dans quelques minutes
parmi les autres thèmes qui vont être
qui vont être abordés par les sénateurs
d'autres questions cet après midi il y
aura les caisses du crédit municipal et
ça c'est une question de l'écologiste
corinne bouchoux là aussi c'est michel
sapin qui lui répond de rentrer à il ya
aussi une question du républicain alain
dufaut sur la situation des festivals
d'été
beaucoup de crédit dans les
collectivités locales ont été coupées en
matière culturelle et les festivals
d'été sont directement touchés c'est la
mise et la culture fleur pellerin qui
répondra à cette question qui est
importante pour beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales qui n'arrive
plus à suivre l'été pour organiser ces
festivals alors on l'entend et bien la
sonnerie de la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vient de
retentir la garde républicaine est en
train de défiler dans la galerie des
bustes vous l'avez vue sur ces images le
président du sénat et le gouvernement se
dirige donc vers l'hémicycle pour une
séance des questions d'actualité quand
je viens vous dire eh bien
essentiellement consacré à la sécurité
avec la lutte contre le terrorisme suite
aux attentats de vendredi dernier c'est
bernard cazeneuve je vous le rappelle le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est
président qui est présent par don dans
l'hémicycle du sénat cet après midi pour
répondre aux sénateurs et puis la
situation de la grèce bien sûr qui
inquiète aussi les parlementaires michel
sapin essaiera de faire un peu le point
sur la situation tout de suite voilà
gérard larcher est installée au plateau
du sénat on écoute cette séance des
questions d'actualité
on se retrouve ici ensuite avec nos
invités pour faire le point sur ses
principaux thèmes à toute la largeur du
the age mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues lors du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
la séance est retransmise en direct sur
france 3 et public sénat
et la première question à notre collègue
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur il y à moins d'une semaine
notre pays a une nouvelle fois été
frappés par le terrorisme djihadiste et
la barbarie la plus digne
à la différence de 2012 à montauban et
toulouse ou de janvier dernier à paris
la décapitation d'un chef d'entreprise
dans le rhône et la tacc contre une
usine de l'isère ont été commis sur des
territoires que l'on pouvait jusque là
qualifié de tranquille où ce type de
violences extrêmes n'avait encore jamais
frappé
aujourd'hui nous savons qu aucune partie
du territoire national n'est à l'abri du
terrorisme
la seule protection et donc leur
enseignement
or monsieur le ministre comme vous le
savez ces attentes un autre point commun
leurs auteurs avaient tous été repéré un
jour par le renseignement français
mais tous sont pourtant sortis des
radars avant de passer à l'acte
l'auteur présumé de l'attentât de saint
quentin fallavier pour ne citer que le
dernier en date avait bien été fiché
entre 2006 et 2008 par les
renseignements généraux
mais ensuite il n'a plus retenu nous
dit-on l'attention de la direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur
pourquoi tous ces profils
une fois entré en phase de sommeil ne
font-ils plus l'objet d'un suivi
est ce juste par manque de moyens
humains comme vous monsieur le ministre
nous connaissons l'excellence de nos
services de renseignement
la qualité et l'engagement des policiers
qui travaillent et j'en profite pour
leur rendre hommage
chacun connaît ici votre souci permanent
de la rigueur et de l'efficacité pour
vous comme pour les services que vous
dirigez et il ne serait en être
autrement quand il s'agit de la sécurité
des français
nous sommes apparemment face à un
problème plus structurelle
d'organisation de service et plus
particulièrement de coordination de la
lutte antiterroriste
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
annoncé hier la création d'un état-major
opérationnel pour la prévention du
tourisme pouvez vous nous en dire plus
sur ce nouveau dispositif
cette structure permettra t-elle une
meilleure circulation de l'information
entre les différents services notamment
entre le terrain
et la prise de décisions au plus haut
niveau je vous remercie pour répondre la
parole et à monsieur bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur devait la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais tout d'abord rendre un hommage
à hervé cornard à dire notre tristesse
dire nos pensées à sa famille à ses
proches je serai demain dans l'isère à
l'occasion de ses obsèques aux côtés de
sa famille et j'ai senti dans l'isère où
mangent me suis rendu une considérable
émotions de la part des élus de la part
des pompiers qui sont intervenus
courageusement auquel je me rendre
hommage et également de la part de
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité dont
vous avez eu raison de dire qu'il
s'agisse de la sécurité publique de la
sécurité intérieure à quel point ces
forces sont mobilisés dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
nous sommes confrontés un phénomène d'un
type nouveau
je n'ai cessé de le dire à l'occasion de
la loi sur le renseignement
ce phénomène d'un type nouveau conduit
des profils très différents
soit parce qu'ils ont des fragilités
psychologiques ou psychiatriques
soit parce qu'ils ont été endoctrinés
soit parce qu'ils ont rencontrés à un
moment donné des ruptures des échecs qui
les ont conduits à basculer à être à
l'origine d'actes terroristes d'une
extrême gravité et le profil dont il est
question celui que vous avez évoqué est
un profil très particulier par rapport à
ceux qui jusqu'à présent ont frappé
qu'il n'était pas dans la délinquance il
n'avait pas de casier judiciaire il
avait été indiqué comme radicalisé mais
aucun élément en provenance des services
de renseignement depuis 2006 n'avait
témoigner d'un risque de passage à
l'acte et par conséquent nous sommes
face à une réalité nouvelle parce que ce
terrorisme est en libre accès sur
internet parce que les profils qui
bluffe basculer sont multiples et parce
qu'il ya une tentative de plus en plus
forte de dissimulation de ces actes de
la part de leurs auteurs ils sont
conseillés d'incidence l'a d'ailleurs
par les groupes terroristes par
l'utilisation du
darknet de la cryptologie ou de moyens
de communication téléphoniques
sophistiqués c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons renforcer les
moyens des services de renseignement
1500 emplois créés depuis le mois de
janvier s'ajoutant aux 500 emplois créés
chaque année depuis le début du
quinquennat 250 millions d'euros pour
assurer la modernisation des
infrastructures numériques et
informatiques
la loi sur le renseignement qui est
centrée sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme et qui doit permettre par la
mobilisation de techniques nouvelles
d'avoir accès aux intentions de ce qui
se dissimule je veux bien entendu par
faire tout ça en décloisonnant les
services parce qu'il faut que
l'information soit échangé c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai donné mission
préfecture conclut réunir l'ensemble des
services autour d'eux et j'ai mis en
place cet état major qui permettra à
l'information de circuler entre tous les
services
merci aux sionistes la parole est à
madame corinne bouchoux pour le groupe
écologiste lever la parole merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
finances et des comptes publics
suite aux mesures annoncées en mars 2015
puis confirmée par le décret du 24 juin
le seuil de paiement en liquide autorisé
pour les personnes physiques ou morales
résidentes en france sera abaissé de
3000 à 1000 euros à compter du 1er
septembre 2015 l'application de ce
décret aux transactions intervenant
entre les caisses de crédit municipal et
leurs clients au titre des opérations de
prêts sur gages pourrait avoir pour
conséquence involontaire de priver de
l'accès à ce crédit à vocation sociale
les ménages fragilisés exclus du crédit
bancaire classique dans la tranche de
1000 à 3000 euros
93% des prêts sont versés en liquide par
les caisses de crédit municipal à leurs
clients et 72 % des remboursements sont
effectués en liquide par les clients
cette préférence pour les espèces n'est
pas fondée sur des motifs condamnable la
majorité des clients ont un besoin
impérieux et urgents des ressources
qu'ils viennent chercher et les 24 à 48
heures induite par l'encaissement d'un
chèque ou d'un virement sont source de
difficultés pour eux mais surtout
nombreux sont ceux dont le compte est à
découvert ou donnent lieu à des saisies
le montant du prêt sur gage une fois
encaissé sur leur compte les descentes
est certes mais ne répondent plus à
leurs besoins immédiats de ressources
si le remboursement du prêt n'est plus
acceptée en liquide les solutions
alternatives pour les clés
en sont inexistantes ou coûteuses pour
beaucoup d'entre eux ils ne seront pas
autorisés à régler par carte bancaire
des dépenses supérieures à 1000 euros le
chèque de banque qui sera alors exigé
est cher et plus lourd à obtenir si
elles sont détournés de l'usaj du prêt
sur gage ces populations fragiles
majoritairement issus des catégories
populaires avec une grande majorité de
femmes devront se rabattre sur des
solutions de crédit plus dangereuse et
plus coûteuses telles que des crédits
revolving voir le recours à des
officines pratiquants l'usure de plus le
crédit municipal et tous les crédits
sont des établissements qui doivent se
conformer aux exigences de la lutte
contre le blanchiment et le financement
du terrorisme
à ce titre elle assure déjà une
surveillance des opérations de leur
clientèle sous le contrôle de la cpr
lors qu'on s'en tenir un traitement
dérogatoire n'est donc pas porteur de
risques significatifs au regard des
objectifs du gouvernement
une clause dérogatoire leur permettant
de continuer à recourir à des
transactions en espèces pour les
opérations de prêts sur gages dans la
limite et 3000 euros pourrait-elle être
envisageable à la lumière de ces
éléments je souhaite connaître monsieur
le ministre les mesures concrètes que
vous comptez prendre au profit des
populations financièrement fragiles et
des caisses de crédit municipal
je vous remercie merci et par le câble
show michel sapin ministre des finances
et des comptes publics avait la parole
mais je suis min merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice madame ma bouche où
vous posez une question parfaitement
pertinente
d'abord parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans le
cadre d'abord parce qu'elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme
les mesures que nous prenons dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres sont là pour
lutter contre les moyens dont peuvent
que peuvent utiliser un certain nombre
de terroristes ce sont vous souvent de
petites sommes en cash qui permettent de
financer des attentats terroristes
extrêmement douloureux nous l'avons vu
en particulier au mois de janvier
dernier donc le gouvernement en
cohérence totale avec les autres mesures
qui sont prises pour lutter contre le
terrorisme a souhaité restreindre un
certain nombre de possibilités
d'utilisation du cash je pense que c'est
une bonne chose et comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même
nous avons décidé d'abaisser le seuil de
paiement en espèces et en monnaie
électronique de 3000 euros à 1000 euros
pour les résidents en france
cette mesure a fait l'objet d'un décret
qui est déjà publiée publié le 27 juin
dernier mais qu'il rentrera en
application au 1er septembre prochain
pour permettre de mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de mesures d'adaptation
je crois que c'est une mesure qui est
raisonnable qu'une mesure qui est
proportionné et d'ailleurs tous les
sondages montrent que les français
utilisent majoritairement des moyens
d'une autre nature que le cash pour des
paiements au dessus de 15 à 20 euros il
n'en reste pas moins que s'agissant des
crédits municipaux cette question peut
poser problème et vous avez décrit vous
même les publics auxquels ils pouvaient
pour lesquelles il pouvait y avoir des
difficultés je vais d'abord pour appeler
madame sénateurs mais vous le savez que
l'article l 112 6 actuelles du code
monétaire et financier prévoit que ces
plafonnement en termes de liquide ne
s'applique pas aux paiements réalisés
par des personnes qui sont incapables
comme le dit le texte de s'obliger par
chèque ou par un autre mode de moyens
ainsi que par celles qui n'ont pas de
compte de dépôt
c'est à dire que ce plafond de paiement
en liquide ne s'applique d'ores et déjà
pas aux personnes qui sont dans
l'incapacité de s'acquitter d'un
paiement autrement qu'en espèces ou
personnes non bancarisées aux personnes
qui ne disposent pas de la capacité
civile pour faire un chèque ou aux
personnes en situation d'interdiction
bancaire donc une bonne partie des
publics que vous avez écrit sont des
publics qui continueront à pouvoir
bénéficier par le biais de ces crédits
municipaux de somme supérieure à 1000
euros il n'empêche qu'il n'engage que
nous souhaitons qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté
vous avez fait une proposition
d'amendement dans le texte dit loi
macron il n'a été déclarée irrecevable
je suis prêt bien entendu dans tout
texte autres dans tout autre vecteur
législatif a accepté un amendement tel
que celui que vous aviez présenté la
parole est maintenant monsieur eric vos
clés pour le groupe communiste
les mimiques des citoyens pour 2 minutes
30 maximum merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des finances et des
comptes publics
dimanche prochain les grecs sont appelés
par voie de référendum à répondre à la
question suivante
acceptez-vous les propositions de nos
créanciers alexis tsipras s'en remettent
à son peuple pour décider en quoi cela
serait-il condamnable je le cite il en
appelle à la souveraineté et à la
dignité que l'histoire grecque exige
nous assistons depuis quelques jours un
véritable déchaînement de déclarations à
charge contre ce gouvernement légitime
expression claire de la volonté d'un
peuple de tourner la page et plusieurs
années d'austérité qui n'ont en rien
amélioré la situation des habitants de
ce pays
la dette est en passé entre 2007 et 2014
de 103% à 175% du pib' cette dette doit
être rééchelonnés sans cette décision la
grèce ne sortira jamais du marasme
les grecs ont déjà consenti les efforts
considérables
alexis tsipras a déjà fait de nombreuses
concessions
la situation de la grèce est grave le
pouvoir d'achat a baissé de 25% les
poubelles ne sont plus collectés
des centaines de boutiques ont fermé on
ne soigne plus les malades dans les
hôpitaux
c'est aussi la démocratie qui est
attaquée aujourd'hui à travers le cas de
la grèce
jamais monsieur le ministre aucun de nos
partenaires européens n'a eu à subir une
telle campagne de dénigrement au delà de
la situation de la grèce c'est toute
l'histoire du projet européen qui est
interrogée aujourd'hui comme le dit le
premier ministre grec
quelle que soit l'issue du vote dimanche
la grèce est et restera une partie
intégrante de l'europe et l'europe une
partie intégrante de la grèce monsieur
le ministre une suggestion d'abord notre
notre groupe propose qu'un débat sérieux
soit organisé au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale sur la question grecque
enfin notre question quelles initiatives
concrètes original solidaire et
audacieuse
le gouvernement français envisage t-il
de prendre urgemment afin d'éviter le
pire à la grèce et donc à nous mêmes
pour vous répondre la parole et à michel
sapin mais des finances des comptes
publics pour deux minutes et demie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs dessinatrice sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur la question puisque
je reprends le terme qui est le vôtre la
question de la grèce c'est pas une
question qui se pose depuis deux jours
ou trois jours une question difficile
abordé par ce gouvernement en dialogue
avec les uns et les autres depuis
plusieurs mois tout particulièrement
depuis que le gouvernement a changé de
majorité
le premier principe que nous appliquons
c'est celui du respect de la démocratie
un gouvernement a changé une majorité a
changé
personne n'a le droit de faire comme si
rien n'avait changé dans le dialogue
avec avec les partenaires européens et
la france a été la première à poser
comme principe le respect de la
démocratie de même que nous devons
respecter la démocratie qui va
s'exprimer au travers d'un référendum et
qui va permettre aux grecs de dire en
répondant à une question qui n'est pas
aussi simple dans son exposé posé que
vous l'avez fait quelle est leur choix
oui ou non par rapport à un processus
actuel de négociations
ça c'est le principe de démocratie le
deuxième principe que nous avons
appliqué c'est celui du dialogue
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à hier jusqu'à hier
après midi
la france a été à l'initiative avec le
président juncker avec le président de
l'eurogroupe pour essayer de trouver de
dégager un accord politique qui permette
à la grèce d'une part à l'europe avec la
grèce d'autre part de trouver une
solution qui soit une bonne solution
hier après midi le premier ministre a
dit ourdi j'organise un référendum c'est
son droit a dit et redit
j'appelle à voter non c'est son droit
mais dans ce cadre là vous le comprenez
bien il n'est plus possible de discuter
de quoi que ce soit pour trouver un
accord d'ici dimanche prochain
quelle est l'attitude qui sera la nôtre
dimanche le oui a des conséquences
elle permet cette réponse du peuple
d'avoir une négociation qui reprend
immédiatement le nom aura des
conséquences elles sont inconnues celle
là
ou très peu connu pour les uns comme
pour les autres pour les uns comme pour
les autres
mais quel que soit le résultat la france
sera là pour maintenir le dialogue parce
que c'est notre spécificité
non pas par différenciation par rapport
aux autres pays européens
mais parce que la france a toujours
était présente pour faire en sorte que
la grèce retrouve la démocratie ou
soient d'entre entre dans l'europe ou
reste dans l'europe la place de la grèce
c'est dans l'euro mais nous ne pouvons
pas le faire nous même tout seul à la
place des grecs eux-mêmes c'est matin
les grecs qui vont en décider
merci monsieur le ministre en parle et à
franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain vous avez la
parole
c'est le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre le meurtre de monsieur hervé
corps nara d'une barbarie absolue
s'ajoutent aux événements tragiques que
notre pays a subi un début d'année
concomitamment d'autres pays comme la
tunisie était aussi confrontés à des
assassinats de masse relevant de motifs
et de logique pouvant être apparentés
ces événements affecte profondément la
communauté nationale et je voudrais à
cet instant est avec vous tous mes chers
collègues salue la mémoire des victimes
et dire notre compassion à l'égard de
leurs proches à l'émotion des derniers
mois succède aujourd'hui de manière
insidieuse l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude d'une sûreté droit
fondamental du citoyen qui ne serait pas
ou plus ou moins bien garantis par les
pouvoirs publics par
l'instrumentalisation et le
développement profond de la religion
musulmane
ces attentats nous disent que leur visée
est exclusivement politique
il s'agit de mettre à bas les
démocraties et les valeurs qui les
fondent pour leur substituer les formes
de terreur et de totalitarisme d'un
certain pays sont déjà le théâtre et
leurs peuples les victimes
dans ce contexte sur son territoire
national comme dans les pays sources de
menaces
je pense à l'afrique subsaharienne la
france et ses dirigeants ont pris leurs
responsabilités et je veux ici saluer
l'engagement de nos soldats et des
fonctionnaires d'état ou territoriaux
qui sont en première ligne depuis 2012
organisation et meilleure coordination
des services de sécurité et de
renseignement loi contre le terrorisme
et pour améliorer l'efficacité du
renseignement lutte contre la
radicalisation augmentation des moyens
opérationnels des services communication
directe et de fonds en direction des
français
tous ces leviers ont été actionnées dans
la cohérence et ont donné un sens
concret pour nos concitoyens à la parole
du président de la république et du
gouvernement
pour autant beaucoup reste à faire pour
que la confiance dans notre dispositif
national de sécurité soient ressentis
par chacun de nos concitoyens c'est bien
une guerre au long cours qu'il nous faut
mener contre la barbarie est pour les
civilisations
une guerre dont l'enjeu central est de
préserver la confiance dans nos valeurs
démocratiques et républicaines
la laïcité n'étant pas le moindre des
principes à faire vivre au quotidien
partout dans l'espace public et pour la
liberté de chacun je voudrais monsieur
le ministre l'intérieur profondément
investi des missions régaliennes qui
sont les vôtres je tiens ici à vous
remercier pour votre engagement
personnel l'autre question c'est
extrêmement difficile monsieur le
ministre
au delà des orientations fortes que vous
avez prises au cours des derniers mois
pouvez vous nous dire quelles mesures
complémentaires vous envisagé de mettre
en oeuvre pour rassurer nos concitoyens
pour vous répondre la parole et amis
sionistes
ce sénateur la lutte contre le
terrorisme
un phénomène que nous avons déjà connu
mais qui prend un visage nouveau gelé
indiqué à l'occasion de la réponse
madame la sénatrice laborde
ce phénomène est un phénomène nouveau il
faut nous armer pour y faire face et
tous les gouvernements successifs depuis
le début des années 2010 ont essayé de
faire au mieux pour affronter cette
difficulté je sais que lorsque il y à
des drames
parfois il ya une tendance à 30 et ses
drames pour faire de la politique est
divisée
je pense que la résilience d'un pays et
des institutions face à un risque
terroriste suppose le rassemblement
suppose aussi le respect à l'égard du
travail des forces de l'ordre qui
s'expose pour sauver la vie des autres
et moi je souhaite que dans le contexte
extrêmement graves auxquels l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne et la
communauté internationale se trouvent
confrontés nous soyons dans la
responsabilité dans le rassemblement de
toutes nos forces autour de nos
institutions pour assurer la résilience
de notre pays deuxième point sur lequel
je voudrais insister c'est sur le fait
que nous faisons tout pour protéger les
français
nous avons augmenté les effectifs de nos
services d'enseignement gelé indiqué
tout à l'heure
1500 recrutement 500 dans les services
d'enseignement territoriale 500 au sein
de la sécurité intérieure 126 au sein la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire
plusieurs dizaines d'emplois au sein de
la direction centrale de la police de
l'air et des frontières parce qu'elles
contrôlent nos frontières au sein du
service de protection des élites des
personnalités et nous allons abonder ces
recrutements d'un effort de près de 233
millions d'euros pour moderniser nos
services
il faut aussi par delà cette efforts que
nous faisons
qu'il y ait davantage de coordination
nous avons été organisée pour faire face
à un terrorisme d'un certain type nous
avons à faire face à un terrorisme d'un
type nouveau il faut décloisonner le
fonctionnement des services c'est la
décision que j'ai prise en donnant une
responsabilité au préfet de zone et en
créant cet état major qui a pour rôle
d'assurer la circulation des
informations troisièmement il faut de la
coopération internationale
ce que nous faisons avec les pays de la
bande sahélienne ce que nous faisons
avec la tunisie pour renforcer les
contrôles aux frontières pour développer
la lutte contre la fraude documentaire
pour renforcer la lutte contre les
organisations du crime organisé va dans
la même direction assurer un haut niveau
de protection des français enfin je veux
insister sur le fait que la loi sur le
renseignement va permettre de mobiliser
pour tous les services des techniques
dont il ne disposait pas et cela nous
permettra de prévenir davantage le
risque était remercié us ministre a
parlé de notre collègue claude kern pour
le groupe de démocrates et indépendants
l'union centriste 2 minutes 30 maximum
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
j'avais prévu d'adresser ma question 1er
mai
je compte donc sur vous madame la
ministre chargée de la famille de
l'enfance et des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie pour nous apporter les bons
éléments de réponse depuis hier les
allocations familiales sont mot de
lucmau des modules et pardon en fonction
du revenu
elles seront divisés par deux pour les
ménages abritant deux enfants est
gagnant plus de 5500 95 euros mensuels
et par quatre pour ceux percevant plus
de 7400 57 euros il s'agit de l'une des
mesures les plus décriés de la dernière
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
elle avait d'ailleurs été unanimement
dénoncée dans cet hémicycle qui l'avait
supprimée mais le gouvernement s'est arc
bouté sur une position qui met à mal le
principe d'universalité
il s'en défend fond dans son
argumentaire sur un subtil distinguo
entre universalité et uniformité endroit
l'universalité existe toujours puisque
tout le monde continuera à avoir droit à
quelque chose mais en fait quand une
famille touchera 32 ou 34 par mois pour
attendre toujours parler d'universalité
bien sûr que non cette mesure
inacceptable mais hélas que
l'aboutissement d'une politique
constante des de détricotage de la
politique familiale depuis le rapport
fragonard du 8 avril 2013
le gouvernement n'a eu de cesse que de
s'y attaquer réduction du quotient
familial réduction du complément de
libre choix d'activité modulation de la
majoration pour les enfants de plus de
14 ans ces mesures ont un point commun
être purement comptable sous prétexte
d'équité on fait des économies sur ce
qui marche on remet en cause l'une des
seules politique française que le monde
nous envie
pour autant est-il normal que des
familles et et touchent autant que des
familles modestes sans doute pas mais il
existe un moyen d'y remédier sans mettre
à mal l'universalité
c'est de fiscaliser les allocations une
solution qui présenterait en dessus cela
avantage de ne rien
coûté aux caf et d'ouvrir la voie à une
réforme de l'impôt sur le revenu ma
question est donc double comment la
module combien la modulation des
allocations va t elle coûter aux caisses
d'allocations familiales et envisagez
vous de revenir dessus pour fiscaliser
le système
je vous remercie on vous répondait pour
maximum 2030
manav rossignol se fait arrêter en
charge de la famille de leïla par le
ministre s'amusait messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur présente monsieur le sénateur
ce qui fait là la qualité l'exception de
la politique familiale française c'est
d'abord qu'elle est plastique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que depuis 1945
elle n'a cessé de s'adapter aux enjeux
sociologiques de la france à l'origine
c'était une politique essentiellement
nataliste celle qui était nécessaire
pour qu'on soit la france et puis c'est
devenue une politique qui permet que la
france soit ce pays européen dans lequel
nous avons à la fois un des taux de
natalité les plus élevés et un taux
d'activité professionnelle des femmes
les plus élevés et c'est ce que nos
voisins nous envie et c'est ce qu'ils
viennent justement étudier chez nous
pourquoi parce que la politique
familiale elle a su se diversifier et en
particulier investir énormément sur ce
qui est essentiel pour les parents qui
est l'accueil des jeunes enfants
pourquoi les femmes travaillent en
france autant qu'elle travaille et
pourquoi nous faisons autant d'enfants
c'est parce que les familles sont sûres
comme mon réseau rend un bébé elles
trouveront dans les infrastructures
collectives
là le mode d'accueil le mode d'accueil
et par ailleurs je pars par ailleurs par
ailleurs dans toutes les communes
je souhaite que je souhaite que dans
toutes les communes
le développement des modes d'accueil
soit une des priorités des mères car je
rappelle que c'est une compétence des
mairies financé par la caisse
d'allocations familiales
les financements sont là il faut la
volonté politique des mers et je
l'attends avec impatience
en ce qui concerne la modulation en ce
qui concerne la modulation
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
prestations familiales
mais pourquoi n'avez-vous pas évoquer
aussi toutes celles qui augmentent le
complément familial pour les familles
les plus modestes
et les plus nombreuses l'allocation de
soutien familial pour les familles
monoparentales qui devait être la
priorité de nos préoccupations
actuellement l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire est aussi la garantie d un
pilier de pension alimentaire qui est
une supplique est versée aux maires dont
les pères dont les maris les ex mari ne
verse pas leur pension alimentaire et
qui se retrouve dans une situation
extrêmement difficile
c'est la politique familiale qui
aujourd'hui vient se substituer au père
défaillant et permettre aux familles
monoparentales
voilà la politique amiens quant à votre
ville quant à votre proposition de
fiscalisation
je note votre audace mais le choix du
gouvernement je conclure n'est pas celui
d'accroître l'effet la fiscalité et de
faire peser sur les ménages des impôts
supplémentaires nous faisons joie des
solidarités ce n'est pas le même la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
mathieu darnaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole votre
cher collègue monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des finances et des
comptes publics
monsieur le ministre au mois de janvier
le gouvernement et la majorité ont salué
l'avènement d'un gouvernement de gauche
radicale en grèce hélas hier comme
aujourd'hui neil aveuglement idéologique
ni le déni des réalités ne permette à
quelque gouvernement que ce soit de
sortir d'une crise et de redresser un
pays alors que les lourds efforts
consentis par les grecs ces dernières
années commencer à porter leurs fruits
avec le retour de la croissance
le premier ministre grec a préféré
gâcher ce redressement par un visa un
virage irresponsable sa gestion
hasardeuse et démagogique et frappé d'un
échec total décrédibilisant la parole
d'un pays qui est pourtant le berceau
philosophique de l'europe et offrandes
assisté à des scènes de files d'attentes
devant les guichets des banques qu'on
pensait d'un autre âge
la grèce et ses partenaires étaient
proches d'un accord mais monsieur trip
type race plutôt que d'entrer dans
l'histoire comme un homme d'état lucide
et courageux à préférer se défausser de
sa responsabilité en convoquant un
référendum comme si excusez du peu il
découvrait le problème
et d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre avoir
un regard critique ne s'y ni avoir un
regard critique ne signifie pas remettre
en cause la démocratie
face à cela monsieur le ministre la
france deuxième économie de la zone euro
est exposée à hauteur de 40 milliards
d'euros et reste pourtant peu audible
non seulement le président de la
république n'a pas réussi à convaincre
le premier ministre grec de renoncer au
référendum mais il a rompu la force du
couple franco allemand
pire encore il a provoqué la mise à
l'écart de notre pays dans la gestion de
cette crise et d'ailleurs j'observe et
nous observons avec intérêt monsieur le
ministre que dans vos propos on note une
certaine inflexion avec des propos
sensiblement différent de celui du
président de la république
à l'opposé la position française les
ministres des finances de la zone euro
se sont finalement aligné sur la
position de l'allemagne
celle-ci assumons à elle seule le rôle
de moteur des négociations et décidant
de ne pas reprendre des discussions dans
l'impasse avancer votre cutié au grand
dôme grecque
monsieur le ministre ma question est
donc simple quand allez vous adaptez la
position du gouvernement français à la
réalité de l'équipe dirigeante grecque
et redonner à notre pays le rôle et
l'audience qui devait être le sien dans
cette crise merci leurs collègues aux
paroles et aux ministres des finances et
des comptes publics ne le soit pas merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices et sénateurs
il ya toute une partie de votre question
qui est la critique en règle d'un
gouvernement étranger
je vous la laisse ce n'est pas ainsi que
nous pensons pouvoir mener le dialogue
avec les uns et les autres
le premier principe que nous devons
avoir c'est celui du respect d'un
gouvernement démocratiquement élu et
d'une majorité est mécaniquement élus
la deuxième chose monsieur le sénateur
deuxième chose monsieur le sénateur je
ne vous ai pas vus c'est normal présent
au sein de l'eurogroupe ce qu'on appelle
leur groupe c'est le lieu où se
réunissent les ministres des finances de
l'ensemble des pays de l'europe ainsi
que la commission le fonds monétaire
international la banque centrale
européenne le tout sous la présidence du
président de l'eurogroupe
la différence entre vous et moi c'est
que moi j'y étais et que je sais quel a
été le rôle de la france
et si vous y étiez ou si vous pouviez
interroger les uns et les autres
vous ne feriez pas ce genre de remarques
qui non seulement est désobligeantes
vis-à-vis de moi même ça ça n'a aucune
importance mais qui est désobligeant tu
vis à vis de notre pays parce que notre
pays joue un rôle fondamental dans le
dialogue actuel dans la capacité à faire
en sorte que toute l'europe
tous les pays de l'euro continue à
dialoguer avec la grèce parce que le
pire qui pourrait arriver
d'abord à la grèce c'est de sortir de
l'euro mais ce serait aussi une
difficulté pour les autres pays et
surtout ce serait une atteinte profonde
à notre projet européen le projet
européen c'est d'avancer et non pas de
reculer
c'est d'accueillir et non pas d'exclure
tel ou tel pays la france a été présente
du bout en bout elle le sera encore pour
faire en sorte que ce soit le dialogue
qui soient au premier plan et puis je
les dis très clairement et n'y a aucune
contradiction
à partir du moment où le premier
ministre hier a dit il y à un référendum
et j'appelle à voter non j'ai dit ce
matin je ne sais pas à conclure un
accord avec quelqu'un qui vous dit non
c'est clair c'est ça et c'est net et
c'est la position et c'est la position
que l'eurogroupe a pris à l'unanimité
et si je voulais trahir un tout petit
peu les débats de cet eurogroupe
c'est moi qui ai fait la proposition
quincy soif qu'il en soit assise fait au
sein de l'eurogroupe à l'unanimité est
c'est normal et maintenant nous
attendons le débat démocratique
le résultat du débat démocratique et ce
sont les grecs qui aujourd'hui vont
avoir à décider
est ce qu'ils veulent on continue à
négocier
dans la sérénité même si c'est difficile
où est-ce qu'ils le veulent prendre le
chemin de l'inconnu je pense qu'il vaut
mieux éviter d'inconnus merci la parole
est à notre collègue jean louis touraine
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues une question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille des personnes âgées
la presse fait abondamment l'écho en
cette période de départ en vacances des
différentes mesures gouvernementales à
effet du 1er juillet souvent cette
période est mise à profit alors que les
têtes sont déjà pleines des perspectives
estivales pour des annonces qu'on
souhaite voir oublier le plus rapidement
possible
il semble bien que vous ayez emprunter
plus tôt la voie d'une meilleure
satisfaction des besoins
trois grandes préoccupations
apparaissent marqué cette fois encore
l'action du gouvernement
premièrement réduire les inégalités et
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux plus
déshérités droit de changer sans frais
d'auto-école assurance chômage augmenter
pour le million six des demandeurs les
plus démunis et c'est bien une mesure de
justice également dans une période de
difficultés budgétaires hérité que de
procéder à la modulation des allocations
familiales
deuxièmement agir en faveur des plus
démunis
par exemple le gaz pour la troisième
fois cette année va coûter moins cher
et troisièmement renforcer la sécurité
de nos concitoyens
l'interdiction courageuse
parce que pas nécessairement populaire
de tous ceux qui concourent à distraire
l'attention du conducteur ou à diminuer
ses réflexes téléphone alcool qui est la
première cause de mortalité chez les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans et limitations de
vitesse parmi ces mesures
trois d'entre elles ont retenu mon
attention les tpe seront exonérés des
salaires et charges des apprentis la
première année l'aide à la
complémentaire santé
et simplifier la question c'est est ce
que pour les apprentis c'est bien l'état
qui va prendre en charge salaires et
charges pour la complémentaire santé
simplifiée pour les personnes aux
revenus modestes profiteront-elles d'une
bosse d'une baisse de leurs contrats de
mutuelle enfin les allocations
familiales sont modulés en fonction des
revenus
elles sont pu calculer seulement en
fonction du nombre d'enfants mais
également en fonction et le niveau de
nos questions merci donc madame le
ministre de bien vouloir nous détailler
plus avant les motifs effets attendus
des mesures les plus fortes
applicable au 1er janvier au 1er juillet
pardon 2015 pas parlé à madame laurence
rossignol secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille monsieur le sénateur jean
louis touraine vous avez en effet évoqué
trois mesures importantes qui indiquent
très clairement la priorité que ce
gouvernement donne pas la donne à la
fois à l'emploi à la jeunesse et à la
politique sociale la mesure en faveur
des apprentis est effectivement une
mesure pour la formation de la jeunesse
est aussi une mesure pour l'emploi et je
peux effectivement vous rassurer c'est
bien l'état qui prendra en charge les
exonérations prévues pour les jeunes et
donc pour leur employeur qui les à
prendre en apprentissage en ce qui
concerne la complémentaire santé
en effet depuis le 1er juillet elle ceux
qui parmi nous sont les plus modestes
qui ont des revenus compris entre 720 et
970 euros par mois pour une personne
seule bénéficieront d'une aide nouvelle
pour souscrire une couverture
complémentaire
c'était de l'ira jusqu'à 550 euros pour
une personne de plus de 60 ans et qui
est une aide significative et par
ailleurs elle est assortie d'une mesure
de simplification
aujourd'hui il ya à peu près 300 offres
qui sont faites plus gars d'offres pas
forcément le consommateur n'est pas
forcément plus éclairés et ils pourront
désormais choisir entre 11 contrats qui
leur seront posées et parmi ces 11
contres alors adhésion une
complémentaire sera effectivement
facilité en plus de la simplification de
l'aide
ils bénéficieront aussi de l'exonération
de la franchise chez le médecin à
l'hôpital ainsi que pour lève les frais
pharmaceutiques
ce qui est une avancée sociale
considérable pour les plus modestes et
ils pourront également demander la mise
en place devait bénéficier du tiers
payant qui se met progressivement en
place
vous le savez une manière très simple
puisque c'est l'assurance maladie qui
paiera en totalité les frais et qui
ensuite se fera rembourser qui est
subrogé auprès des organismes
complémentaires
vous avez évoqué effectivement la
modulation des allocations familiales
qui est une mesure de justice sociale et
je vous remercie de l'avoir indiqué
ainsi personne n'at il n'a échappé à
personne le rapport de l'unicef sortie
d'un beau moins de trois semaines qui
évoque pour la période 2008-2012 qui est
la période qui a observé ce rapport une
à une
un accroissement considérable du nombre
d'enfants vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté plus 400 mille enfants vivent
sous lé seuil de pauvreté et au total 3
millions d'enfants
c'est notre priorité et les familles qui
aujourd'hui voient leurs allocations
familiales moduler savent qu'elles ne le
font pas en vain elles le font pour plus
de solidarité et pour que notre pays
puisse dire que l'enfance est une grande
cause nationale qui rassemble tout le
monde et toutes les familles merci la
parole et que notre collègue jean pierre
vial pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue ou
même chez brillant et messieurs les
ministres mois la question est à
l'intention de monsieur lemay intérieur
en qualité d'élu de la région rhône
alpes et plus particulièrement d'un des
trois départements considérés comme
sensibles au sein de notre région
nous sommes bien évidemment et tout
particulièrement interpellée par les
récents événements de saint quentin
fallavier et mas aussi bien évidemment
aux propos tenus à l'instant peu notre
collègue montaugé face à une situation
dont les actes montrent tous les jours
un peu plus la gravité et l'ampleur
nous ne pouvons qu'adhérer soutenir le
discours volontariste du président de la
république et de vous-même monsieur le
ministre nous ne pouvons qu'adhérer
également la déclaration du premier
ministre concernant son engagement total
contre le salafisme des frères musulmans
mais derrière cette déclaration
d'intention permettez moi de vous
interroger concrètement sur certains
aspects de la politique du gouvernement
au moment où le parlement vient de
débattre du texte de la sécurité en
sachant le rôle de premier important
joué par internet et les réseaux sociaux
concernant les salafistes le gouvernant
tunisian vient de réagir fermement à la
suite des derniers événements en
décidant la fermeture de 82
les salafistes or nous avons en france
un nombre équivalent d'établissement de
lieux de prière concernant les frères
musulmans nous connaissons les mesures
prises et envisager à leur égard par
plusieurs pays de la méditerranée pour
sortir de la radicalité de leurs
discours
or non seulement aucune position
semblable est affichée en france à
l'égard d'organismes ou d'établissement
qui relève clairement de la doctrine des
frères musulmans
mais au même moment la position du quai
d'orsay sont bien différentes des propos
du premier ministre dans les alliances
et stratégies déployées au moyen-orient
en un mot la position du prion de la
république de vous même le ministre
l'intérieur du premier ministre ne
peuvent qu'obtenir notre soutien total
mais encore convient-il que le
gouvernement nous précise sa politique
face aux décisions à prendre et aux
contradictions constatée entre la
politique intérieure affichée et
certaines orientations de la politique
étrangère du gouvernement et pour vous
répondre
un parent lointain monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le sénateur votre question est
pour moi l'occasion de faire un point
extrêmement précis sur un certain nombre
de sujets vous avez évoqué qui relève
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup de questions de
politique intérieure de lutte contre le
terrorisme à l'intérieur de nos
frontières
je veux parler de la lutte contre l'
toutes les formes de radicalité et
contre notamment les radicalité violente
qui peuvent s'exprimer en appelant à la
haine en provoquant torisme dans un
certain nombre de deathmatch numérique
ou dans les mosquées que faisons nous
d'abord vous avez des inquiétudes sur la
détermination qui est la nôtre a procédé
à l'expulsion de ceux qui profèrent ses
propos il ya non seulement une fermeté
totale
mais tout ce qui d'après les services de
renseignement ou les services de police
se livrent à la provocation de propos
appelant à la haine provoquant au
terrorisme sont systématiquement
expulsés
je veux d'ailleurs pour vous rassurer
vous donner des chiffres depuis 2012 ce
sont 40 d'expulsion de prêcheurs de
haine qui sont intervenus depuis le
début de l'année 2015 c'est dix dossiers
d'expulsions qui sont quasiment abouti 6
expulsions sont déjà prononcés et 22
dossiers en instance
pendant la même période
du quinquennat précédent alors que le
risque était très élevé comme en
témoigne la fermera ou d'autres affaires
c'est 15 expulsion qui sont intervenus
en cinq ans là où nous en avons fait 40
ans 3 ans et je ne céderai pas face à
ceux qui sont des propagateurs de haine
dans le pays ils n'ont pas s'ils sont
étrangers leur place en france
ils seront expulsés premier point la
déchéance de la nationalité vous en
parlait souvent la déchéance de la
nationalité
si déchéance qu'une procédure juridique
très complexe
depuis de 2012 il y en aura d'autres
pour tous ceux qui ont la double
nationalité et qui se livrent à la
propagation de discours de haine dans le
pays il y a aujourd'hui aussi des
dossiers en instance d à main ils iront
à leur terme
troisièmement les mosquées salafistes il
y a des règles de droit
elles sont dans notre constitution elle
nous liait l'union européenne
s'il ya des associations qui dans leur
entièreté dans les mosquées contribuer à
la dimension de pensée de l elles seront
dissoutes j'ai indiqué qu'il y avait des
dossiers en cours d'examen au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur mais le seront
dans le respect des règles du droit
constitutionnel et du droit européen
parce que ne pas le faire reviendrait à
lutter contre le terrorisme dans
l'abandon des valeurs de la république
donc je vous le redis la fermeté du
gouvernement est totale prétendre le
contraire ne correspond pas à la réalité
de ce que nous faisons et cette fermeté
je l'exprimerai à chaque instant sans
trêve y pose face aux risques
terroristes
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue christian manable pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
chargée donc des transports de la mer et
de la pêche
la commission européenne a très
récemment dévoilé les propositions de
subventions pour le financement des
infrastructures de transport dans les
états membres
et cela dans le cadre du mécanisme pour
l'interconnexion en europe au moment où
certains
s'interroge parfois sur l'avenir de
l'europe et sa valeur ajoutée pour notre
vie quotidienne et notre destin commun
au moment aussi où certains demandent le
rétablissement des frontières et le
repli sur soi
je souhaite que vous puissiez monsieur
le ministre éclairer ces décisions
européennes et préciser les projets
retenus ainsi que leurs probables impact
sur nos territoires et notre économie
si l'objectif est d'achever des réseaux
transeuropéens important en matière de
transport d'énergie et de
télécommunications
notre priorité demeure d'accroître la
mobilité des citoyens et d'améliorer les
biens et les services dans l'ensemble de
l'union européenne
en complétant les liens manquants dans
les réseaux en éliminant les goulets
d'étranglement et en favorisant des
équipements structurants
or ce réseau de transport augmentera
incontestablement la cohésion économique
sociale et géographique dans l'union et
créera des emplois tout en garantissant
un bon équilibre entre la protection de
l'environnement et le développement des
infrastructures comme par exemple les
voies de navigation intérieure alors
avec les grands projets de transport
d'intérêt européen et je pense en
priorité au canal seine-nord europe tant
attendu par les acteurs économiques les
élus la population de la nouvelle grande
région nord pas de calais picardie et je
voudrais ici saluer la mission qui a été
bonne et la mission de reconfiguration
menée par le député pauvros
je voudrais aussi cité le tunnel
ferroviaire long lyon turin est aussi
tous les projets autour du réseau ferré
ou encore de nos ports je pense en
particulier à calais le havre rouen avec
également les projets portant sur la
mobilité verte
ce sont au total des décisions
importantes pour le report modal vers
les transports les moins émetteurs de
gaz à effet de serre ok si haut si j'y
arrive ce président guy aussi je
souhaite monsieur le ministre que vous
puissiez nous détailler ses projets
précisé le calendrier évaluer leur
impact économique et aussi en termes
d'emploi je remercie
merci on vous répondra pas roulé comme
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur effectivement lundi la
commission européenne a publié les
résultats du premier appel à projets sur
le mécanisme pour l'intégrer
interconnexions en europe dit m y est un
projet global de 13,1 milliards d'euros
de subventions données et par l'europe
la france est avec un montant de 1,76
milliard le premier bénéficiaire sur la
période 2016-2020 de ces crédits
européens
je salue la confiance que nous témoigne
l'europe en particulier sur deux projets
très importants que vous avez cités qui
sont le lyon turin et le canal seine
nord europe qui est chacun se voit
attribuer une subvention de 40 % des
travaux c'est notre travail patient mais
résolue grâce à l'action notamment du
premier ministre qui a relancé ses deux
grands projets au cours de l'année 2014
par cette action l'europe accompagnera
est la politique des transports du
gouvernement et qui est résolument
orienté vers le report modal et la
responsabilité budgétaire
parmi les projets bénéficiaires de
subventions on retrouve les projets
visant à améliorer l'accès scène comme
la ligne serqueux gisors
l'approfondissement du chenal du port de
rouen
la résorption de goulets d'étranglement
ferroviaires comme les noeuds de
strasbourg et mulhouse mais aussi les
lignes du grand paris express des
nouvelles mobilités ne sont pas en reste
de nombreux projets encourageant la
mobilité électrique et les projets de
transports intelligents le gouvernement
travaille depuis un an sur l'ensemble de
ces dossiers c'est un succès pour la
france que de voir ses nombreux projets
retenus permettront de construire une
europe intégrée reliant ces territoires
grâce à des corridors performant et
durable
le gouvernement restera mobilisé
puisqu'il y aura un second appel à
projets qui sera lancé à l'automne 2015
l'europe concrétise ainsi son action sur
les transports d'une manière vi
les responsables elle accompagnera la
france dans la construction d'un réseau
fort et d'un secteur de l'économie des
infrastructures
cela contribuera très positivement au
développement de la croissance de notre
pays au moment où la critique de
l'europe nourrit le populisme d'extrême
droite
je suis heureux de rappeler que l'europe
c'est aussi la construction ensemble
dans l'avenir
et si la parole est à monsieur alain
dufaut le groupe l'est républicain avait
la parole nos chers collègues
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre la culture à l'occasion d'un
colloque au dernier festival de cannes
le 17 mai dernier le premier ministre a
estimé que la baisse du budget de la
culture
au cours des deux premières années du
gouvernement de françois hollande était
un signe négatif et votre prédécesseur
madame amis seraient dus philippe itil
le lendemain sur france info n'a pas
manqué de commenter cette réaction de
manuel valls en précisant je la cite je
me suis battu pendant deux ans pour
lutter contre cette baisse je n'ai pas
du tout été écouté une baisse de 6 % sur
deux ans c'était du jamais vu même sur
la droite
fin de citation même si la remarque du
premier ministre va peut paraître
désobligeantes à l'égard de son
prédécesseur à matignon
il n'empêche que les réduction drastique
du budget culturelles conjugués aux
réductions des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales rendent à
l'équation budgétaire culturel
totalement insoluble pour les élus
locaux que nous sommes forcés de
constater sur le terrain que l'austérité
est de rigueur dans le domaine culturel
et que c'est la signature de décéder
festival adossé désormais au sein de
subvention municipale
prenons l'exemple d'un département où
olivier py directeur du festival
d'avignon festival qui va débuter samedi
vient de raccourcir de deux jours la
durée du festival
car la subvention municipale a été
réduite de cinq cent mille euros par le
maire socialiste d'avignon
qui je le reconnais ne pouvait pas faire
autrement vous le savez madame le
ministre demi le festival sont organisés
chaque année en france et malgré l'appel
cause avait récemment lancé aux
collectivités locales qui se trouve face
à des choix budgétaires très difficile
vous ne pouvez pas exiger qu'elles
stabiliser leur financement culturel
les élus locaux sont en effet dans
l'obligation de posséder une égard au
contexte financier contraint un tour de
vis sur les subventions accordées aux
associations à caractère culturel et en
particulier sur les festivals de nos
départements
alors madame la ministre à l'heure où
plus que jamais je dis bien plus que
jamais notre pays un besoin évident de
culture
que comptez vous entreprendre pour
sauver ces festivals de province qui
soit théâtre de théâtre musical qui
jusqu'à ce jour trouvé la majorité de
leurs financements
environ 70 % auprès des collectivités
territoriales
merci on nous raconte la parole et alain
fleurent purin maëlys de la culture la
parole si monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur merci pour cette question
qui effectivement préoccupe tout comme
vous et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs je voudrais apporter un
certain nombre de précisions d'abord je
ne reviendrai pas sur le passé je ne
commenterai pas le bilan de ma
prédécesseure puisque ce serait
discourtois
mais est-ce que je tiens à dire
néanmoins c'est que s'agissant des
festivals
vous le savez très bien et vous avez
rappelé vous même les chiffres il y a
plutôt entre 2000 et 3000 festivals en
france l'état le ministère de la culture
n'en soutien des partenaires financiers
que d'une centaine d'entre eux une
dizaine de très grands festivals à
rayonnement international
sur ces 100 festival l'engagement
financier de l'état n'a pas varié au
cours des deux dernières années au cours
des trois dernières années
donc l'état le ministère de la culture
ce gouvernement n'a pas sacrifié sa
participation au prêt aux côtés des
festivals qu'il avait pour tradition
d'accompagner donc vous l'avez dit c'est
un choix politique c'est un choix
politique le choix de la culture est un
choix politique ce gouvernement qui
réalise 50 milliards d'économies a fait
le choix budgétaires de maintenir
et même d'augmenter le budget du
ministère de la culture donc je répond
également à votre question vous me
demandez que comptez vous faire
et bien déjà moi je considère qu'un
budget monsieur le sénateur un budget
c'est toujours des crédits au service
d'un projet donc je ne suis pas dans une
logique incrémentale où je demande
toujours plus d'argent pour avoir plus
d'argent
je souhaite proposer un certain nombre
de projets et j'ai des priorités qui
sont le soutien à la jeune création et
la transmission des savoirs l'éducation
artistique et culturelle et c'est pour
financer ses projets que je me bats
auprès du premier ministre ou auprès de
mon collègue secrétaire d'état en charge
du budget dans les discussions que nous
avons actuellement pour défendre nos
budgets pour défendre le budget du
ministère de la culture
vous savez bien qu'en ce moment au lieu
les discussions budgétaires
c'est pour moi important de défendre un
projet et ensuite de défendre un budget
qui soit au service de ce projet est
donc le gouvernement a fait le choix
politique de maintenir le budget de la
culture alors que par ailleurs nous
réalisons beaucoup de d'économies pour
pouvoir être responsable budgétairement
et réduire le déficit public de notre
pays ce que nous avons fait depuis deux
ans alors que vous même ne l'avait pas
fait donc sur les festivals moi ce que
je souhaiterais vous dire c'est que j'ai
confié une mission à pierre cohen pour
pouvoir objectiver la situation parce
que vous conseillez vous dites que les
festivals ont ont été annulés mois je
souhaiterais vous dire que c'est l'avis
des festivals également parfois de
disparaître parfois d'être créée il ya
de nouveau créé 50 faut conclure qu'ils
ont été créés l'année dernière donc il
faut objectiver la situation et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé à
pierre cohen de médée est d'aider les
élus aussi à comprendre la raison
les raisons qui font que des festivals
sont aujourd'hui en difficulté
je ne manquerai pas de vous en tenir
informés merci nous en avons fini avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues j'ai reçu
hier un rapport de monsieur jacques
grosperrin au nom de la commission d'
enquête sur le fonctionnement du service
public de l'éducation sur la perte de
repères républicain que révèle la vie
dans les établissements scolaires et sur
les difficultés rencontrées
par les enseignants dans l'exercice de
leur profession créée le 22 janvier 2015
là les initiatives du groupe l'est
républicain en application de l'article
16 bis du règlement
voilà c'était donc cet après midi la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement au sénat on se retrouve
tout de suite pour refaire ensemble la
séance sur ces différents thèmes et
après la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on se
retrouve ici dans la salle des
conférences du sénat juste à côté de
l'hémicycle pour refaire ensemble cette
séance des questions d'actualité
évidemment dominée notamment aujourd'hui
par la situation en grèce avant
d'interviewer notre première invitée
gens visés le président de la commission
des affaires européennes du sénat je
vous propose de réécouter dans
l'hémicycle du sénat c'était il ya
quelques instants
michel sapin sur la grèce jusqu'à hier
jusqu'à y